effectivement il a fait une sortie
d'affaires traitement de faveur c'est
pas parce qu'on est gay bon enfin après
il a fait une sortie qui était
évidemment moi je trouve catastrophique
et voilà qui prônait un séparatisme
dramatique mais en plus c'est dans un
contexte d'élections présidentielles où
tout le monde le récupère tout le monde
instrumentalise mais c'est donc à
darmanin qui lui court après parce que
chacun veut bien montrer qu'il est ferme
qu'il n'y a pas de de règles suivant
qu'on est très connu ou pas connus voilà
donc c'est impossible et puis j'aimerais
bien savoir pourquoi gims va être
français en fait c'est ça pourquoi il va
être français bien évidemment quand on
est français
pas un battant il peut avoir envie de
bien mais qu'il a gonflé après que
jamais qu'ils avaient raison pourquoi il
a trois enfants la grosseur
il habite au maroc il gagne sa vie grâce
à la france il n'est pas né en france il
a grandi en france certes mais moi je
voudrais savoir pourquoi il va t
il et il est pas né en france c'est pour
ça qu'ils vont être naturalisé enfin
s'ils étaient nés en france et
il est venu en france la vie c'est la
france a averti sa vie personnelle à la
virtualisation il a été refusé parce que
il ya des règnes en fait j je suis
désolé oui mais c'est vrai il y avait
des critères ben voila mais là on
critères si ça remplit pas les critères
hebei par benjamin d'abord roulant déjà
en plus il a été il est allé en france
malade tout l'argent qu'ils gagnent
payent pas d'impôts en france déjà
commencé par ça si c'est vrai ça
vous dit des bêtises
ou tel que les droits d'auteur excusez
moi ça s'exporte très bien à l'étranger
il s'est elle qu'un trait commun chabal
mais j'ai toujours que si la majorité de
ces enfants
viennent de la faune excuse moi tout ne
reste pas en france excuse moi c'est un
fait comment vous avez c'est quoi
l'histoire non mais c'est un fait ça et
bien quoi les droits sont tous les tous
les we déjà et tous les artistes se
réalise pour les droits d'auteurs soient
bien des droits d'auteur pour qu'ils
soient pas taxés en france en direct
mais qui fait ça ne va pas bien
mais on parle de kilos oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
être dit c'est votre
moi je comprends qu'on s'organise ne
peut pas à la fois dit peut être
français et puis ils sont passés de
l'année
alors ça je suis pas ni amendable une
peinture si la finition c'est une
portière et oui non mais que ce soit la
course à l'échalote et que tout le monde
mieux pour la course à l'échalote voir
après gims aujourd'hui ça fait bien
pendant la période de l'élection
présidentielle de se montrer ferme de se
montrer dur en disant regardez comme
nous on fait attention et c'est bon ça
c'est indéniable bien évidemment mais on
essaie de récupérer quelque chose qui
existe déjà depuis 2013 s'il a déjà fait
une demande en 2013 il avait été refusé
je la refais demande en 2010 elle et qui
lui a également été refusé donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya un lien
il ya eu des rayons mais invaincu dans
le parisien qu'il estime une série de
choses pour lesquelles peut-être il ne
rempliraient pas les conditions pour
être naturalisé et des conditions
visiblement il ya quelque chose qui
pêchent guînes alors que nous on n'a vu
qu'une histoire de polygamie l'aefo
compte 110 ans est folle après et gaby
c'est faux
je
sais exactement la situation personnelle
qui vous battez j'étais voilà les jeux
c'est l'arrêté c'est la course à
l'échalote
dit comme ça mais au physique
mais monsieur lâm si les interrogations
frère toc et la deuxième fois parce que
j'étais la plus justifiée de 50 domicile
l'année entière en france mais on a
évolué non maintenant il est domicilié
il vit beaucoup mais parce que je sais
j'en habite avec lui toi mais je connais
le dossier et je connais bien mais c'est
des naturalisations aweys est inquiet et
sur la première et sur la polygamie
c'est un faux procès qui lui est fait il
est il a été marié civilement qu'une
seule fois ce qui est vrai ce qui est
vrai c'est que sans doute il ya deux
mariages religieux l'un des deux
mariages religieux n'a pas plié et et
n'a pas fait de demande de légalisation
sur papier en france donc ce n'est pas
considéré comme de la polygamie c'est ça
la situation il n'est marié femmes
voilées vois ce que je veux savoir moi
je suis pour que kim c'est ce même bien
s'il en est juste il ya des règles
est-ce qu'ils respectent les règles est
ce que il ya c'est à dire que si il est
comme toutes les personnes qui demandent
la nationalité française et qui rentrent
dans les critères cwi ben si voilà ce
que vous mettez dans le fret est
toujours là le défenseur le maître gims
à ce que je connais tu peux toujours le
vengeur masqué
bonjour masquer ce
soit tu fais je t'adore oui
j'imagine bien que le ministre
t'imagines si ministre il y va à guimps
diramba dans la foi dans les critères
mais il le donne à guy
fawkes estimé d'ailleurs mais c'est ça
il faut que ce soit pareil pour tout le
monde j'ai mon 2008 les choix champions
tenait
[Rires]
alors le seul critère qui reste
aujourd'hui ce serait la non adhésion
aux principes et aux valeurs
essentielles de la république française
lle d'arman c'est ce que monsieur
darmana divers sa vidéo d'ailleurs pour
ça que que gims je vous donne une info
s'est excusé parce qu'on lui a dit
pareillement torah si tu ne s'excuse pas
tu n'auras jamais la nationalité mais la
dharma valais et darmanin n est pas il
est piloté
mais j'ai pas dit ça il aurait peut-être
dû attendre un peu il soit ou pas sont
ils à saint sava voyez là c'est sa c3
envie de sincérité toi le dos et non
alors toi ton toi de tes pieds il ne
reste plus de critères objectifs pour
que gims ne soit pas française tout ce
que je vais bien et toi même si tu vas
le
jean bernège à blanc vêtue verdien le
critère qui des fois cyril franchement
adhésion aux principes et valeurs
essentielles du nord vous voulez si ses
proches ont dit qu'ils auraient pas dû
dire ce qu'il avait à dire avec un
problème hein c'est mon père est
derrière vous avez raison j'ai ouïe
[Rires]
et
moi et moi je suis pour que m et ça n'a
été ni se défendre et il peut pas avoir
deux poids deux mesures rien des gens
qui font tout comme la france réalise
moi j'aime la france aimerait bien des
mecs qui m'ont aidé à temps et nous on
n'a rien fait on aime la france on
travaille en france est déjà menée voilà
on paye nos impôts approche et guillaume
sidiya j'aime pas qu'on souhaite mon
anniversaire et mont houy tiré de l'eau
il a la nationalité maintenant je vais
te dire là il va falloir il va se passer
au moins six mois nous le dira voilà je
n'en a pas et imaginons alors j'essaie
hydraulics ou alors si le président
sortant reste ça va être compliqué alors
si c'est valérie pécresse ou quelqu'un
d'autre je pense que ça va être encore
pire que ça sera examiné à la loupe ah
ouais je me tenir donc là là en fait ils
l'auraient pas du tout qu'il aurait pas
nous mêmes en fait il en avait parlé à
brigitte macron qui n'a pas souhaité
donner suite au dossier je reconnais
qu'il ya des points faibles dans le cdma
zellidja gueule quoi qu'il en soit la
mégane en attendant ce que même s'il n'a
pas envie de lui donner oui on est
désespéré maintenant ils ont dû se dire
[ __ ] oui pourquoi il a dit ça c'est
quand tu as envie de te qu'un mec ne
fasse pas de conneries il aime bien et
que tu as envie d'une année son truc il
joue bien mais pourquoi ces politiques
alors pourquoi pas donc c'est po l'ena
des éléments contient des éléments
laissant pas moi c'est comme quand tu
vas ouvrir un compte chez les lourds
pour faire un compte téléphonique on te
demande ton chèque bahri ben voila si tu
l'as pas là tu dégages oui
comme vous je veux pas de passe droit
parce qu'ils s'appellent gims moi j'en
est vrai le côté impôts puisque vous
parlez d'un pot si on parle d'un pot je
pense qu'il en paye assez en france plus
que quelqu'un d'autre qui ait fait
naturaliser ça on va pas parler d'un pot
on parle pas d'argent on parle juste de
qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche la pourquoi
monsieur darmanin lui donne pas la sueur
à lyon parce qu'il n'a pas dix bonnes
années parce qu'il veut jouer
sur celle ci on n'est
pas des bonnes années je voudrais depuis
deux hivers
l île vous devine 6-2 puis 2013 il
m'apprend qu'il vous est il depuis 2003
et 2006 depuis 2013 il ne permet pas
un autre carton jaune à la carte
d'identité il vient de kinshasa y montre
il montre qu'il a réussi en france il ne
l'oublié pas qu'il est quand même un
modèle de russie la paix religieuse
regard dur oubliez vous en laisse un
modèle de réussite pour les amériques
xining chine sous six mois laurent je
connaissais déjà cocktail pour li pou
retour d'image j'aurais préféré que la
france lui dise bah voilà on va te
donner on va te donner la nationalité
non pas parce que c'est pourquoi
avez vous changé répond pas aux critères
je savais qui donne la nationalité à des
balades en quoi encore qui font
jour là et ces gens là la nationalité
mais qu'on le crie on irait pour les six
derniers mois il a dit un critère tout
de suite donné moi
d'abord tu dois passer des tests
devraient suivre dont les postes étaient
ceux qui ont la crise il les a passées
les a eus les tests démontrent que tu
assimiler la langue française la culture
française d'accord ensuite tu dois être
domicilié depuis un an régulièrement et
là je conteste nos informations avancées
techniques ne doit pas être par exemple
polygame tu dois répondre à l'adhésion
aux principes et aux valeurs
essentielles de la république française
et tu ne dois pas déroger il doit passer
au jeu les gens qui ont la nationalité
française il ya des gens qui grâce à ils
ont pas de femmes au pays les gens ça
c'était tout ça pousse il s'en servir
comme ça sinon sénat
ouvrez les yeux et mais je suis bien
qu'ils ont des fans
se donne la patte conjoint ou la
conjointe très ouais
il ya derrière